one of the incredible things that has
happened in the context of the russian
invasion of ukraine is that much of the
world has become united against russia
and in defense of ukraine you look at
the list of countries now sending
military support weapon support rather
to ukraine it's an incredible list and
with some rare exceptions i mean you
know
uh belarus and you know the the typical
handful of exceptions
much of the world
has not been as united for or against
anything as we have seen over the last
week and as i've said before the the
ukrainian president zielenski was not
particularly popular before this started
and there are still
all sorts of concerns when it comes to
corruption in ukraine as we've talked
about before
but the degree to which he has become
what you know often i say as a joke
defiant and principled but he has
remained defiant and principled in a way
that people of the world over are really
rallying behind
and most recently uh with a
quite frankly a viral speech
to european parliament during which
you'll hear the translator
become audibly emotional
leading to a minute-long standing
ovation after the second clip let's take
a listen and this is the voice of the
translator that you will hear
we're fighting
just for our land
and for our freedom
despite the fact
that all life cities of our country are
now blocked
nobody
is going to enter and intervene with our
freedom and country and believe you me
every square
of today no matter what it's called
it's going to be called
as today freedom square in every city of
our country
nobody's gonna break us
we're strong we're ukrainians
and of course um
the hope would be
that indeed
ukraine will be able to repel the
invasion from russia we don't know that
know that yet and if it doesn't happen
it will not be from lack of desire
or resolve it will be because of the
sheer size of the russian military and
uh the most recent uh reports are
that kharkiv is increasingly surrounded
and you know it's so hard to know what
is really going on because you many of
the reports that have come out later are
retracted or were based on confused or
incorrect information
uh but the desire is there and here's
more from the ukrainian president
selenski
ending his speech before european
parliament
to a minute long standing ovation so do
prove that you are with us
do prove
that
you will not let us go
do prove that you indeed are europeans
and then
life will
win over death and light will win over
darkness glory be to ukraine
[Applause]
so as you can tell uh quite a united
planet at this point in time and there
are as always conflicting reports coming
out of russia on the one hand when it
comes to the military front like i just
said reports that kharkiv is in an
increasingly precarious situation as of
the last three four hours uh surrounded
and that things are not looking good at
the same time there are multiple reports
that putin's grip so to speak on power
may be starting to slip at least
ideologically
yahoo news daily beast article rather
the russian people may be starting to
think putin is insane
and i encourage you i mean listen i
encourage people to read all of the
things that are being written and
understand that what really happened if
we will ever fully know the story it's
only going to be in retrospect
but we will of course
continue covering what is going on
and hope
hope
that indeed ukrainian forces and allies
are going to be able to repeal uh repel
uh this horrifying invasion and we will
continue talking about what the what the
next steps may be and uh quite frankly
joe biden's state of the union address
tonight which we'll be covering live
may give us some of that information in
the meantime there's much more to talk
about here and i want to talk next about
an incredible statement made by the
ukrainian ambassador to the united
nations